teame I'm going
to give a lesson in Japanese from now on.
First, read out the definition of souvenirs.
It's a nuisance, but it's a fusion of things that you can get, such as
sexual
illness.  I'm gonna buy souvenirs
Michimoto Winter vacation I'm going to
Seattle where I have some plans Seattle
I'm gonna meet you souvenirs I don't need anything
If you don't want to buy souvenirs because you don't need them, you have to buy souvenirs for all the offices
.
Michimoto-san, I have some plans for winter vacation
. I'm going to see the whole Sailor Moon building. After I like Sailor
Moontis, I don't think it's cool yet.
If I were a ninja, I would definitely be at home.
Thank you, Michimoto-san, I have no plans for winter vacation.
Michimoto, I have some plans for winter vacation.
I don't need it, Mr. Yamamoto, I
can't put anything in it. I
understand that it's just my wife, or I can buy Im this time.
No, thank you for that souvenir.
Mr. Tanaka, it's been a long time, and the one who was surprised is nice. I'm sorry
Ozawa, who brought this from Tokyo
. Thank you for coming back from Shanghai.
If you don't mind buying this locally, please eat it together.
So there are a lot of mugs and towels that aren't open at home. If
the method I mentioned earlier is very convenient, it may not work 100%, so even through souvenirs.
When you have to buy it is contaminated
or recommends liquor When it comes to souvenirs, if the shrimp avoids a safe option
, it seems to be Johann Ribe
[Music]
How is
it?
[Music]
I
'm a
police officer.
I know your patient, Richard Brown.